in our last lesson we talked about a
couple of things we talked about what
the principle of Relativity means in
general relativity isn't a new thing it
boils down to how two people can see the
world very differently
however when people say the word
relativity they usually mean Einstein's
theory of relativity which is a special
and mind-bending case as I hopefully
convinced you in the previous lesson we
have a real and experimental data that
proves that at very high speeds are when
very precise measurements are made two
clocks will ticket different speeds and
that observers will disagree on the
length of an object depending on whether
they see the object moving or not
so those last two things are pretty hard
to accept but they're quite true
they arise from two core principles the
first is that all observers no matter
their speed compared to other people
have an equal right to claim that they
are the one unmoving center of the
universe
that's not so new and unusual we've
accepted that since the days of Galileo
the second one is much less obvious and
that is that the speed of light is the
same for everyone and by much less
obvious I mean it sounds absolutely nuts
after all if you're sitting on a
high-speed train with a kitten in your
lap you'll reasonably say that the
kitten isn't moving on the other hand
someone sitting stationary the train
crossing gates watching your train fly
by will say that the kitten is moving at
something like 60 miles per hour
it seems that velocities always depend
on the frame of reference in which
they're measured
but it's not true for light and we know
this to be true we'll get to how we know
that later in the lesson for the moment
it might be interesting to get a sense
of how we measure the speed of light and
other interesting consequences of this
very bizarre fact
the speed of light is very fast indeed
it's the fastest thing in the universe
numerically is about 186 000 miles per
second
that's about fast enough to
circumnavigate the Earth about seven and
a half times per second
I said about when I gave the speed of
light an old style American units it's
easier to State the speed of light
precisely in the metric system where it
is exactly 299 million 792
458 meters per second
I know that to be precisely true because
that's how the meter is now defined that
definition was agreed upon in 1983.
that level of precision is important for
scientists but it isn't so crucial for
our conversation thus around the speed
of light up to being 300 million meters
per second or 300 000 kilometers per
second
so measuring something that fast takes
some doing I mean it's not like sound
which is slow enough that there can be a
perceptible delay I'm talking about
places like a baseball game where you
can see the distant battery hit the ball
and hear the crack of the bad a split
second later or when you see a
high-flying plane overhead and hear this
Allen coming from a different location
with a speed of 770 miles per hour just
over a thousand feet per second it's
easy to understand how a location
determined by hearing and vision would
be different after all if the speed of
sound is a thousand feet per second and
you're looking at a plane that is flying
at an altitude of thirty thousand feet
you'll hear the sound coming not from
where you see the plane but from where
it was 30 seconds ago though with light
any possible delay in any reasonable
situation is imperceptible by human
senses
instead of the full second it takes for
sound to reach a thousand feet it takes
light a millionth of a second
so how can we measure the speed of light
well basically you either have to
utilize very fast Electronics or measure
very long distances and the second
method is how the speed of light was
first measured
the first professional attempt to
measure the speed of light was made in
1676 by Danish astronomer oleiromer he
was making precise measurements of the
eclipse of the moon IO as it orbited
Jupiter attempting to determine the
exact moment in which IO slipped into
Jupiter's shadow
this wasn't the esoteric exercise it
seemed to be it actually had
applications for Sailors needing to
determine their location on the globe
it's a fascinating Story how determining
a ship's longitude depended on having an
accurate clock you should look it up
what Romer knew was that IO takes 42.5
hours to orbit Jupiter from that he
could calculate the moment at which the
eclipse should occur for every orbit
however what he found was that his
calculation and measurement disagreed
furthermore the disagreement changed
over time and depended on where Jupiter
was in its orbit compared to where Earth
was in its
those two locations were constantly
changing which therefore changed the
distance between Jupiter and Earth
using precise measurements and a lot of
thinking Romer realized that he could
explain his observations if light had a
fast but finite speed
he even calculated the light would take
22 minutes to travel from one side of
the Earth's orbit to the other and from
that he calculated that the speed of
light is 220 000 kilometers per second
which is about 26 percent lower than the
actual speed but still it was an
incredible achievement for someone
working over three centuries ago
those old guys knew their stuff
of course we can repeat romer's
measurement today and get more accurate
results but now we have fast electronics
and we make different measurements they
more directly measure the speed of light
for instance we can set two light
detectors a thousand feet apart and then
shoot a pulse laser from one to the
other and measure that light took a
millionth of a second to travel that
distance
or we could use a single light detector
and a dist mirror to do the same thing
a millionth of a second sounds very fast
but even an inexpensive modern
oscilloscope can easily measure time
durations a thousand times shorter
however measuring the speed of light is
one thing proving that it's the same for
all observers is a bit harder
let's look into that a bit
so just how did scientists figure out
the speed of light is the same for all
Observers
let's talk about two methods the first
one to conclusively approve the
conjecture and then the more modern way
to do it
our first Story begins in the middle
years of the 1800s when researchers had
an unsolved question and that question
is what conducts light
remember that in the early 1800s Thomas
Young had demonstrated pretty
convincingly that light was a wave
furthermore Einstein's photoelectric
effect was still decades in the future
time the wave theory of light was pretty
much unchallenged
the problem is that waves don't move
like particles do throw a baseball and
the ball moves from one spot to another
but if you put a rubber ducky on the
surface of a lake far from the shoreline
and watch the waves roll in what you see
is that the ducky mostly moves up and
down but doesn't actually get closer to
the shore
the wave is the movement of energy
through the water but the water or the
ducky doesn't move in the direction the
wave moves
a similar thing is true with sound waves
with sound waves air molecules move back
and forth but the air itself doesn't
experience any net motion the details of
how the air molecules move are different
from the water example but that really
isn't important here
what is important is that for all waves
known to 19th century scientists the
waves needed a medium like water or air
to pass through
a second important feature is that
relativity applies to most waves and by
that I mean ordinary 17th century
Galilean relativity
that means that if you were on a
fast-moving train and yelled from one
end to the other you'd measure a speed
of sound however a person standing on a
train station watching the train Zoom by
would measure a different speed of sound
sounds travel through a media and when
we talk about the speed of a wave we
mean the speed when the medium is
stationary
the problem for 19th century scientists
is that there didn't seem to be anything
through which light could travel
after all space is completely empty
totally devoid of matter and light from
distant Stars makes it to the Earth
of course scientists of the era didn't
know with 100 certainty the space was a
vacuum although they were pretty sure
but they certainly had made Hollow glass
vessels and pumped all of the air out of
them leaving only a vacuum and when they
did that it could see through the glass
and see whatever objects were on the
other side of the glass it was clear
that light could pass through a vacuum
and if light could pass through a vacuum
the question was what was the material
through which light was transmitted
there was a proposed answer that
originated in the 1600s when the
question of the wave or particle nature
of light was raging
those who held to the wave theory of
light proposed that the substance that
transmitted light was called The
luminiferous Ether or just ether for
short
ether was first proposed in ancient
Greek time this is a substance found
above the Earth what was called the
terrestrial sphere back when such names
as Plato Aristotle and Ptolemy were
leading intellectual luminaries
and the 17th 18th and 19th century ether
was thought by some to be a substance
that permeated the entire universe it
was everywhere and conducted light
there were a few issues with ether one
thing is that it wasn't something that
people could directly observe so that's
a problem without observation you don't
know if it's real or if it's like
discussing how many angels dance on the
head of a pin
the other problem is that in general
waves travel quickly through very stiff
and dense materials and slowly through
ones that are low density or that can
move easily for instance sound tends to
travel quicker through liquids than
through gases and quicker through solids
than liquids and even with solids sound
travels faster through stiff materials
like steel and slower through materials
like clay
if you want a cool fact sound is 17
times faster in steel than an air
light as we have seen is extremely fast
that suggests that the material that
carries it should be solid and very very
stiff yet of course we'd notice if the
universe were solid and stiff so this
was a bit of a problem
proponents of The Ether simply table the
problem as a mystery still to be solved
there was another aspect of light and
The Ether that troubled the late 19th
century scientist and that was the
question of whether the ether was moving
or whether the Earth was moving through
the ether or what
and this particular question was made a
little more Concrete in the early 1860s
when Scottish physicist James Clark
Maxwell pulled together a ton of work by
earlier researchers and invented what we
now call Maxwell's equations
Maxwell's equations describe how
electric fields and magnetic fields
interact and how we really shouldn't
talk about electricity and magnetism
independently but rather that there is
but a single phenomena called
electromagnetism
so that was a pretty big deal but it
wasn't Central to the question of light
however the connection between
electromagnetism and light became
Crystal Clear when Maxwell used his
equations and combine them taking a dash
of electricity in a dollop of magnetism
combined with a pinch of calculus and a
generous splash of algebra he combined
his equations and showed that they
predicted that there existed
electromagnetic waves furthermore he was
able to calculate the speed of
electromagnetic waves and it turned out
that his equation said that they moved
at the speed of light
mind you this is a little different from
saying that light actually was an
electromagnetic wave but it would have
been a huge coincidence if it wasn't and
remember this was before Einstein
published his work that showed that
light was also a particle so people were
pretty convinced that Maxwell's work
showed that light was simply an
electromagnetic wave
however I've glossed over something here
I said that Maxwell's equations said
that the electromagnetic waves traveled
at the speed of light but from the last
lesson we need to be cautious the speed
of light
speed of light relative to what
the obvious answer was that Maxwell's
equations predicted the speed of light
with respect to the luminiferous ether
and if that's true then it meant that we
might be able to measure the motion of
the earth Through The Ether and that
brings us to an effort in 1887 when
American physicist Albert Michelson and
Edward Morley perform what is now known
as the Michelson Morley experiment at
what is now Case Western Reserve
University in Cleveland Ohio
in lesson three we talked about how
Thomas Young sent light through two
different slits and made a series of
bright and dark spots on a distant
screen
whether the spots were bright or dark
depended on a shift between the waves
coming from each of the two slits which
I remind you physicists call a phase
shift
if the peak of one wave coincided with
the peak of another wave the result was
a bright spot if the peak of one wave
coincided with the trough of another
wave the result was a dark spot
the important thing is the shift between
two waves
so Michaelson and Morley decided to do a
similar thing although the details were
pretty different
first let me describe their apparatus
they started with a beam of light that
they shot at what is called a half
silver mirror
half silvered mirror reflects half of
the light and lets the other half pass
through
you make a half syllable Mirror by
putting a very thin reflective coating
on a piece of glass
so that half silvered mirror was
positioned at a 45 degree angle with
respect to the beam that means that half
the light pass through in a straight
line while the other half was reflected
at an angle of 90 degrees compared to
the original light
after passing through the half-silvered
mirror the two beams were traveling at
right angles to one another
they then placed two full-strength
mirrors to reflect those two beams of
light back to the half-silvered Mirror
the reflected beams both passed through
and were reflected by the half-silvered
mirror and this recombined the two beams
onto a screen where they could be seen
here's where the phase thing comes into
play
depending on whether the two beams of
light arrived in Phase with the Peaks
enhancing one another or out of phase
with Peaks and troughs canceling the
results would be either a bright spot or
a dark spot
the pattern on the screen is just a
little more complicated than I described
but that's the big idea
before I get into the speed of light
part of the experiment I should say that
this experiment was extremely sensitive
to vibrations after all the wavelength
of light is less than a millionth of a
meter less than a thousandth of a
millimeter vibrations that would make
one light path a tiny bit longer or
shorter would cause the pattern to
flicker between bright and dark spots in
fact their equipment was so sensitive
that someone stomping their foot at a
distance away the length of a football
field would ruin their measurements so
to minimize the vibrations they put
their apparatus Underground
that helps a lot but not enough so they
mounted their entire apparatus on a
heavy Sandstone block and floated the
Block in their equipment in a pool of
Mercury
Mercury as you probably know is a very
dangerous substance that can be deadly
it's especially dangerous to unborn
children but Michelson and Morley were
most certainly not carrying unborn
children and it was the 1880s so OSHA
didn't exist I showed her to think what
my laboratory safety board would say if
I proposed their experiment today
but times are different and their
apparatus did suppress vibrations
because the Sandstone block was floating
in a pool of mercury you could also spin
it and this is a critical feature
so this brings us back to The Ether
according to the thinking of the time
The Ether permeated the entire universe
but we knew that the Earth rotates and
orbits the sun and it was likely that
the sun moves through the cosmos and
that meant that it was very probable
that the Earth Moved Through The Ether
alternatively The Ether could be thought
of as a kind of a wind blowing across
the Earth
because the michelson-morley apparatus
shot two beams of light at 90 degrees
with respect to one another that meant
that they could rotate their apparatus
so one arm was in the direction of the
wind while the other was perpendicular
to it and if the speed of light is
defined with respect to the ether that
meant in Michelson and Morley's lab
light would travel at different speeds
through the two arms if light traveled
at different speeds that would affect
the phase of the Waves passing through
the two arms and that would affect the
expected pattern on the screen
of course the experimenters didn't know
the direction The Ether was passing
through the Earth but here's the beauty
of the experiment they could rotate
their apparatus which means that they
could move the arms to be parallel to
the movement of The Ether or
perpendicular and even if they didn't
know which was which they would expect
the speed of light between the two arms
to change as they rotated it that means
that they should expect to see changes
in the patterns of brightness and
darkness on the screen
if they saw these changes they would
have discovered the ether
so what did they see in a moment totally
worth of a drum roll what they found was
exactly zero nothing there was no change
at all in the pattern of light and dark
seen on their screen and the only
realistic explanation for this is that
the velocity of light in both paths
didn't change with orientation and from
that it logically follows that the
michelson-morley experiment killed the
idea of The Ether
now the idea of The Ether didn't die
immediately people thought of possible
explanations like the idea that the
Earth was dragging along the ethers that
orbited the Sun so The Ether in the
vicinity of the Earth was stationary as
far as the Earth was concerned but the
michelson-morley experiment was
certainly the beginning of the end
a series of researchers thought about a
variety of possible explanations but
slowly one by one they were all
falsified until we are left with
Einstein's conjecture which is that The
Ether doesn't exist and that all
observers measure light as traveling at
a single and unique speed which is about
300 000 kilometers per second
physicists use the symbol C that's a
lowercase C to indicate the speed of
light by the way here's a bit of physics
trivia the symbol C was chosen to tie it
to a certain Latin word celeritus which
means speed or haste now before I change
topics I wanted to tell you about a
different method for showing the speed
of light is the same for all observers
and undeniable and modern measurement
demonstrates that all observers see the
speed of light to be a single value this
measurement involves my specialty
particle accelerators
first let's start with a low speed
example suppose you're a pitcher for a
professional baseball team if you try
hard you can throw a baseball about 100
miles per hour sounds hard my shoulder
aches just thinking about it
but that's what they can do
now let's put the same picture in a
fast-moving train traveling at 100 miles
per hour with respect to the track
that's a fast train in the U.S but quite
slow compared to for example the tgv in
France
if we did this in a person standing
stationary next to the tracks were to
measure the speed of the baseball they'd
see that it was moving at 200 miles per
hour that's 100 miles per hour from the
pitcher's arm and 100 miles per hour
from the train itself pretty
straightforward
you can do a similar experiment using a
particle accelerator and I want to
remind you that this isn't a thought
experiment this is something we do every
day we're talking hard data here
we can start by taking an electron and
inducing it to emit a photon let me
remind you that photon is a particle of
light
we can measure the speed of light in a
straightforward Way by simply setting up
two stationary light detectors a fixed
distance apart and measuring how long it
takes for light to go that distance
divide the Distance by the time and you
get the velocity and you find that it's
300 000 kilometers per second
now we use a particle accelerator to
shoot the electron down the accelerator
at nearly the speed of light and when I
say nearly the speed of light I'm
talking extraordinarily close in an old
style television like your grandparents
watched the electrons traveled at
something like 20 the speedo light but
even in the most modest modern particle
accelerator made it can accelerate
electrons to
99.99999 the speed of light
in decimal form that's 0.999
etc for a total of nine nines so that is
to all intents and purposes essentially
traveling at the speed of light
following our baseball example if we see
an electron traveling at the speed of
light and it emits a beam of light the
the electron sees traveling at the speed
of light then we should see that light
is traveling at twice the speed of light
and if that's the case we should expect
to see this super fast beam of light
arrive at the far detector and half the
time it takes the electron to travel
that distance traveling the same
distance at twice the speed takes half
the time common sense
except that's not what we see the
electron an emitted Photon travel the
prescribed distance and essentially the
same amount of time the photon and
electron both travel at the speed of
light
and obviously this makes no sense if the
speed of the electron is added to the
photon no sense at all it only makes
sense if the photon is traveling at the
speed of light both to the point of view
of the electron and to you who sees the
electron zooming along at very high
speeds furthermore this experiment gives
the same result for any time of day and
any time of year this means that if
there were any effects due to traveling
through what we now know to be The
non-existent Ether either in the
direction of The Ether flow or
perpendicular to it we'd see it that's
because the orientation of the
accelerator changes over the course of
the days and the years
when you get right down to it this
modern measurement is inarguable proof
that light travels at one speed for all
Observers
so I hope that I've convinced you that
the speed of light is universal to all
observers which is a very
counter-intuitive concept but it's
experimentally true this truth leads to
all of the crazy sounding predictions of
special relativity which I talked about
in the previous lesson those have also
been tested and found to be true further
validating the claim that the speed of
light is the same for everyone but there
are some other fascinating facts that I
thought you'd be interested in
one such thing has to do with the claim
that the speed of light is the same for
all frequencies of light or wavelengths
if you prefer that way of thinking about
it remember from lesson three that Max
Planck and Albert Einstein deduced that
the energy of a photon of light depended
directly on the frequency of the light
therefore low frequency light has low
energy and high frequency has high
energy
now for particles a low energy particle
travels at a lower speed than high
energy particles this is something you
know from common experience a high
energy bullet can do more damage than a
low energy bullet of the same weight and
caliber
so it wouldn't be foolish to imagine
that perhaps low energy light might
travel at lower speeds than high energy
light but we know this isn't true we
know it to incredible precision
the way we know this is by using an epic
cosmic explosion called a gamma-ray
burst
exactly what causes a gamma ray burst is
not known there are several different
hypothesized causes but what we do know
is that they are brief emissions of
energy that are the brightest things in
the cosmos they can be seen literally
from across the universe they can be as
little as two seconds and as long as a
couple of minutes and they emit all
sorts of light from the lowest energy
radio waves to the highest energy gamma
rays the gamma rays can easily be
hundreds of billions or even trillions
of times higher energy than the lower
energy light it's a huge difference
as it happens we have a variety of
astronomical observatories they can see
all wavelengths from gamma rays x-rays
ultraviolet visible infrared microwave
radio waste the whole smear
and that means when a gamma ray burst
goes off we can time the arrival of the
electromagnetic energy in all
wavelengths and frequencies
one gamma-ray burst occurred in 2009
with the unimaginative name grb 090510
it exploded literally a long time ago in
a galaxy far far away about 7.4 billion
years ago the light traveled for all
that time and the different wavelengths
all arrived within a few seconds of one
another
let's think about what that means
7.4 billion years is about 200
quadrillion seconds
the initial arrival times were all
within two seconds that means the
various different energy photons which
means frequencies of light all arrived
with a difference of no bigger than one
part and 100 quadrillion that's
unfathomably small that's like measuring
my height with a Precision of about 1
100 the size of a proton or if you're an
astronomy buff the distance to Alpha
Centauri with a Precision of about a
foot
the different wavelength light traveled
at the same speed to ridiculous
precision
this measurement combined with the
observation that the speed of light is
the same to all observers so something
very deep and fundamental about the
universe mind you we don't know exactly
what it is but it's clearly telling us
something
I'm going to return to the speed of
light in Lesson 16 when I talk about
gravitational waves it turns out that
gravity also has a speed and we've
measured that too
that's its own level of scientific
awesomeness
before that though we have some other
fascinating topics to talk about
see you soon